ty wouldn't what went into your decision
process in terms of you know a lot of
people they want to make a web series
and then they want to then a band in the
web series and they want to move on to
making feature films what wanted to your
decision processes are like make a first
series and then go on and make a second
season of a web series for a second
there I did think about making it a
feature but i just wanted to it came
down to where I made the decision I'm
just being like let's keep it to a web
series I think for me personally doing a
feature is going to be a different story
it's not going to be this story I feel
like this particular story fits for what
this medium is new media web series and
keep it as that I have seen some web
series though that their second season
they're making into a feature so that's
it that's a way to go and I I don't know
but you still have that first season
that you sort of need to adapt for
screen now you know but but that's not
the decision I'm making sure is it is
that your question okay there's more
commitment to budgets way higher and
it's very reasonable what you're hoping
across 14 yeah the other thing too and
art actually told me about this his
contracts sag it's harder with the
future right now we have sag new media
that's how we're doing season two and
that's what we did see the one and
that's more flexible it gives me more
freedom and intense to make it yeah
without the restrictions yeah there
would be no way on earth you could do
this if you tried making it as a film
under the ultra low budget it's yeah now
with my mom no unless you want like do
nothing with it yeah literally show it
nowhere do nothing just say I had sag
actors in my my movie and I'm keeping it
on my shelf yeah it's pretty much was
mom and dad one location any mormon know
exactly what occasion my apartment come
on really buddy so there's that the
technical logistical end of things that
prevent you from making a feature film
on the kind of budget that we're doing
so
you